okay so up top if you've been following
the channel for a while now then you'll
know that i don't intentionally rip into
things for the sake of doing it
i'm not a get what go broke andy sjw
type youtuber
who just talks about things in the
negative light to cause drama
and get clicks however what ezra miller
and cbs have done in general with the
stand in this episode
is so bad that it's bordering on
offensive and i have no clue
why they thought it was a good idea now
i'm not in the best of moods with cbs as
it stands
but not intended as since starting my
breakdowns they put claims on a number
of videos
and had them blocked from being
monetized i do this as a full-time job
and rely on the revenue that's brought
forward from videos
so that i'm carrying this out on
something especially when i wasn't even
ripping into the show
it gets super frustrating it kind of
makes doing the videos a waste of time
as i could be working on something
that's not gonna get flagged
and will get me money instead but i know
you guys are enjoying the videos
so i persevere i've been trying to give
these guys the benefit of the doubt
but clearly it's not happening from
their side so
screw them at this point after watching
the opening of this episode i've just
had the little goodwill i had for this
show
killed completely now in the source
material the trashcan man
is a pyromaniac he's fascinated with
setting trash cans alight
hence the name and though he suffers
from a mental illness
i think even if you watch the original
mini series
then you'll know that he comes across
more as a crazy person
than someone who's disabled now i don't
know if i'm putting my own impressions
and life experience before what the show
is trying to portray here
but i did have a disabled relative who
passed away last year
and the betrayal that ezra gives seems
like he's trying to ate that
but he isn't doing anyone any favors in
2021 i just think this is such a bad
take
and i have no idea why anyone allowed it
to happen
when he's strutting slowly through the
tankers with his jaw
sticking out bent wrists making velocila
raptor sounds
and then jacking off to fire it just
paints out people with disabilities
in a very very bad light it's almost a
caricature of someone suffering from
something that they can't control
and it doesn't pain people out with
disabilities in a sympathetic or
understandable light
i'd heard for a while from people that
had been given early access that ezra
went too far with his performance
and to go from him to then tom cullen
being bossed about and tread on
it just seems such bad taste they did a
lot making tom cullen seem like more
than his disability
but unfortunately they took 80 steps
back to the 1970s
and pretty much derailed the entire
season with this opening
whether this video gets blocked hidden
from view i'm not really bothered
and i think that cbs should be very very
ashamed with themselves
sorry i had to get off my chest now who
as always
this is the heavy spoiler show i'm your
host paul welcome i guess
now let's get into the breakdown now i'm
actually interested to see if people
agree with my rant or not
so hit the thumbs up button if you do
and down if you don't also we've got
just three episodes left of the season
so make sure you subscribe in order to
not miss the breakdowns
terrible opening one of my worst ever
but one of the main reasons that i think
this episode fails in its portrayal of
the trash can man
is because we get absolutely no idea who
or what he really is
in the book his backstory and journey to
vegas is far more fleshed out
and we see that he deals with paranoia
from the electroshock therapy that he
received as a child
however there is a callback to him
wetting the bed
and the line that people who play with
fire do this appears in both this
version and the mini series
it just doesn't feel like it's developed
enough though and therefore he just
comes across as a completely alien
character
that doesn't feel like he fits in with
the rest of the cast
in the original work he tries to
sabotage a big part of the stronghold in
vegas
and he then goes and gets a nuke as a
gift for flag in order to repent
however here he's definitely recruited
and this is the great fire that the
antagonist is referring to
now in boulder harold informs nadine
that mother abigail has disappeared
and he shows her the explosive that he's
constructed
in the original work it's hidden in a
cupboard whereas here it's placed into
the top of the piano
now this does work slightly better i
think as last episode abigail did show
nadine in audiences that she leaves the
top open
and this is pretty much how nick figures
out that something is amiss
now this is rigged to go off during a
vigil for abigail
and this differs from the source
material as in that it was just at a
committee meeting
i did think last week that the mention
of the cinema night by harold would mean
that that would be the target for his
and 18 schemes
but that's revealed as being more for
the kids though i have no idea why they
put so much focus on that
at the expense of other things now one
thing that is massively cut down
is the arc that judge varus goes on in
the source material there's a big
shootout that happens as the character
waits outside the town
here it's completely emitted from the
episode and the judge is killed off
camera and then taken to vegas
flag wants her alive so that he can find
out where tom is
as due to his mental capacity he's
unable to unearth his location
all he's able to see is the moon and tom
now interprets the run note as meaning
the moon
and thus makes plans to escape in the
book the character just takes his bike
and makes it out of dodge silently
whereas here he hides amongst the bodies
in order to go out undetected
now one of the more interesting aspects
of this episode
is nadine's arc we hear joe talk for the
first time
and he very much divulges the dichotomy
and duality
that exists within her she clearly can
be kind and caring
due to her being a teacher that looks
after the kids she even wants to stop
joe from going to the vigil
and also makes it so that larry won't be
near the explosion when it goes off
however we also know that she's a killer
who will gladly murder people on mass
for randall flagg last week we saw as
nadine went to larry and clearly wanted
to sleep with him
but here she ignores it and avoids
discussing it with the character
now whereas she was once the driving
force between her and harold
the roles are very much reversed here
with him being the one that wants to
kill everyone
he comes to mother abigail's and heads
out with stew
and this gives fran the chance to go
into his house which is where she makes
a big discovery
whereas the show has been cutting things
down in regards to abigail we get far
more of a fleshed-out story of when she
wandered into the wilderness
similar to jesus who went into the
desert she's tempted by
flag who promises to make her problems
go away
he actually hints to how old he is after
saying that he was present at a number
of crucifixions
and it becomes clear that he's been
trying to take humanity over for a while
the thing with flag is that he's had to
wait until humanity was powerful enough
to destroy itself
and this of course came with the
manufacture of captain tripps
now he's trying to sweep the survivors
up and start again with them under his
rule
but abigail rejects his offer saying
that god will be able to find her
no matter where flag hides her away
there's also a moment in which he says
he has many names
and is legion for he is many this quote
comes directly from the bible
namely the book of mark and it's what
was given as a reply when jesus asked
the demon's name
he blows her with a huge gust of wind
and this could be a reference to the big
bad wolf
who metaphorically has appeared in a
number of king's work
abigail states that she knows flag is
afraid that people in vegas will see him
for what he really is
and this does start to happen in the
episode when he brutally butchers the
leader of a biker gang that was sent
after judge varys
it's clear that people are deeply afraid
of flag and now this city of sin was
initially
labeled as heaven by lloyd the fact that
you can get torn limb from limb for
saying no
shows that it's actually a tyrannical
society
flag is an almost all-seeing and
all-knowing god that is ever-present
and him brutally beating the gang member
for all to watch
shows that he leads with fear rather
than because people like him
he tears the guy or rather the fake
dummies throw out
and is that not just the worst wig
you've ever seen i tell you what cbs you
really let us down
go go ahead demonetize the video after
tearing his heart out he overhears julie
talking about mr moon
aka the one thing that flag sees when
trying to look up who the spy is
however it's too late and tom makes his
escape
before he's caught this failure in
getting dana to confess
capture faris alive and take tom in
shows that he isn't as powerful as he
believes he is
and it hints to us that though godly
he's not unbeatable
elsewhere harold and stu go into the
woods and the former almost dozen of
mice and men on the latter
as he talks about his life stu seems
genuinely to be suffering from
survivor's guilt
and he doesn't really know what his
place is even though he was clearly
chosen for a reason
he's saved by the head of the city watch
who states that due to abigail's age
and being just in a nightgown that it's
unlikely she's still alive
fran starts to explore harold's basement
and here she discovers the surveillance
equipment
as well as his manifesto though this
scene wasn't in the original work
i think it's very akin to the shining in
which wendy does the same thing
and that was actually made up for the
movie as is this moment for the show
but it's nice that the two are linked in
some way as we know from the first
episode
harold was obsessed with the fantasy
that he would be the last man left alive
with a woman
and that the pair would fall in love his
story was rejected numerous times
and he sees himself as being cheated out
of having the life he always wanted
the in-cell side of him really rises to
the top and even though franny almost
makes it through to him
he locks her in the basement now clearly
this is to keep her out of harm's way
and the same thing happens in regards to
nadine who makes it so that larry is
kept safe whilst things go down
joe goes to the woods and here he finds
abigail
he alerts others by screaming and fran
escapes the basement and makes it to the
vigil
now it seems like she's done a lot of
damage to her body
and whether this causes a miscarriage or
not we don't know yet
in the book this isn't really the way
that things go down so they could change
it but that remains to be seen for the
moment
now the people of boulder pile into
abigail's house but after she's found
this
stops saving many of them from being
inside when it blows up
nick however isn't so lucky and after
noticing that the piano lid is closed
he lifts it to discover the device
inside which detonates not only killing
him
but also a lot of people surrounding the
house harold and nadine detonate it
together
and look over the carnage which is when
we cut to the credits
ending the episode anyway that wraps up
the entry
and obviously uh lots to talk about and
i'd love to hear your thoughts on it and
whether you agree with mine or not
i don't forget that on the 30th of
january we're giving away three copies
of the hobbit and a lot of the rings 4k
box sets to us subscribers all you have
to do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
the links to our socials are in the
description and you can also support the
channel by clicking the join button
and as a thank you you get videos like
this early if you want something else to
watch then make sure you check out our
do-overs of one division
or this stand or you know anything in
general that we've done on the channel
it's it's all worth watching i promise
and without the way
thank you for sitting through the video
i mean paul i'll see you next time
take care peace